ich hatte heute auch ein thema sehr
bewegt und dieses thema ist eigentlich
ein sehr persönliches was ich auch sehr
traurig macht den stellen sie sich vor
sie selbst krank sie haben gerade eine
schwierige diagnose bekommen und werden
das krankenhaus eingeliefert ich habe
das zum glück nicht aber viele menschen
in diesem land haben dass sie geben
selbstverständlich ihren liebsten
bescheid und die wollen auch direkt zu
ihnen kommen aber das krankenhaus
verwehrt den einlass der grund die
korona bestimmung ich möchte ihnen hier
ein paar beispiele geben dem uniklinikum
essen ist nur eine person pro tag pro
patient erlaubt in den sana kliniken in
düsseldorf ist es noch schlimmer in
duisburg dort ist nur ein besucher pro
patient erlaubt und das nur für eine
stunde das heißt sie müssten dann
entscheiden ob sie geht jetzt der vater
geht die tochter und das nur für 60
minuten am tag das war's in vilnius
kliniken duisburgs extra noch erwähnt
dass kindern der zutritt als
begleitperson derzeit nicht gestattet
ist ich kann nicht verstehen wir das als
gesellschaft erlauben können wie die
politik das tolerieren kann ich bin mir
bewusst ist bei den betreibern das
hausrecht gilt aber ich finde dass wir
auf begehren müssen die cola
beschränkungen den krankenhäusern sind
für mich ein verbrechen
[Musik]
sagen ja das stimmt also ich hab selber
gerade erlebt ich musste mich einer
operation unterziehen und am morgen vor
der op also nüchtern wenn man da etwas
aufgeregt ein scheck wurde mir erst mal
gesagt ja hierher besuchsverbot also
hier darf gar keiner kommen niemand
niemand die ganze zeit über nicht und es
hat auch niemand für nötig gehalten
einen darüber mal aufzuklären ich kann
verstehen dass gerade die betreiber von
kliniken natürlich sorge haben wenn sie
jetzt wieder ein kommunaler ausbruch
haben wenn ihr personal krank wird das
dann natürlich viel dran hängt aber ich
glaube wir haben es auch mit einer
mentalität zu tun die sich bestimmte
abkürzungen angewöhnt hat in der kurzen
zeit bestimmte regelungen die für chefs
für organisatoren angenehm sind das gilt
übrigens nicht nur für kliniken auch für
den ganzen dienstleistungsbereich wo es
also immer noch so ist dass man
sozusagen bestimmte sachen jetzt vor
schreibt die überhaupt nicht mehr nötig
sind und ich glaube wir brauchen jetzt
echt mal ein umdenken nach kroner und
einfach mal neu gucken was ist jetzt
wirklich existenziell nötig und was ist
einfach faulheit und frechheit ich finde
es auch sehr schockierend weil wir haben
auch gerade einen fall und dann habe ich
dort angerufen und dann meine schwester
mehr bitte besorgt die sondergenehmigung
damit wir beiden hin dürfen und da muss
man sich schon ganz klar fragen da habe
ich mich schon ziemlich beschissen
gefühlt dass ich ja meiner kleinen
schwester sagen was ja hoffentlich
bekommen wir beide die sondergenehmigung
war ansonsten können eine von uns hin
oder niemand aus der familie also eine
person dafür aber wer geht dann und mich
hat das dann so sehr beschäftigt dass
ich das heute an auch mitgebracht habe
und diese verschiedenen kliniken gemacht
habe was ich mich nur frage ja mit zwei
juristen am tisch ist jetzt nicht das
juristische thema es ist ja auch die
hausordnung der betreiber aber kann man
nicht irgendetwas juristisch dagegen tun
frau sachtleber hat das ist eine gemeine
frage gleich zum auftakt ein jura
studium ist eine weile her und ich bin
garantierten ihrem hausrecht will corona
fragen
firmen
persönlich finde ich das auch absurd
diese ganze thema
das ist eine regelung die wurde glaube
ich 2020 eingeführt und spiegelt einfach
überhaupt nicht mehr das wieder wo wir
jetzt im infektionsgeschehen sind also
ich weiss stationen sollen von allen
stolz ich weiß ich weiß also ich bevor
wir das juristisch das machen würde er
an den gesunden menschenverstand
appellieren da kann ich besser helfen
ich habe das bereits 20 20 mal geprüft
also da waren menschen die konten nicht
zu ihrem schwer kranken leuten
verabschieden sich nicht verabschieden
obwohl sie wussten sie sterben in einem
tag da hab ich geprüft das kann doch
nicht sein das darf doch nicht sein das
ist doch das wichtigste für menschen ja
noch von sin geliebten abschied zu
nehmen da spielen natürlich alles
mögliche reihenhaus ordnung wer ist
träger des krankenhaus wer ist träger
des heims und so weiter also ich
persönlich würde mir das antun würde ich
würde klagen bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht und zwar mit
einem 2 liegen anordnung sollten die das
regel das geht nicht es gibt nicht nur
die körperliche gesundheit es gibt auch
noch die züchter
sie haben sich den betreiber
herausgesucht das kommt drauf an also
das kommt drauf an alle die mir in die
tiefen der juristerei jahr haben die
möglicherweise eine monopolstellung
müssen hier auf irgendeine art diesen
kranken den betreuten übernehmen da gibt
es ganz ganz viele da könnten sie eine
deutliche tazio darüber schreiben ich
persönlich halte das was jetzt auch noch
gemacht wird ja die beschränkungen für
nicht mehr vernünftig herr müller sie
arbeiten ja auch beim öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk wie sieht die
debatte dort aus also wir sind schon
hier am tisch ja wie man auch merkt sehr
stark gegen diese bestimmung wird diese
debatte auch geführt bei ihnen in der
redaktion die debatte wird natürlich
auch geführt aber kontrovers und die
wird nicht nur bei uns geführt wird
denke ich in allen medien äußeren
geführt und zwar nicht nur im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk sondern auch bei
den printmedien und in anderen häusern
es gibt keine man kann ich sagen dass
dann eine konkrete für
aber es gibt eben ein sehr
obrigkeitliche verhalten auch nicht also
wenn man dann machen sie das mal also
das hat ja auch ein effekt und ich denke
hier schwerer man ist desto schlimmer es
hat ja auch einen effekt auf die
heilungschancen dass man sich also ein
bisschen grün und aufgehoben fühlt dort
und ich frage mich dann häufig auch beim
personal also wenn man dann sagt aber
ist das jetzt klug ist es wirklich nötig
man zum beispiel die charité soweit ich
weiss macht das mit tests und masken das
ist sondern auch wenn ich darf kommen
ich versuche ja zu schützen wo es wo es
dann geht kommt sehr häufig so von
mitarbeitern na ja das ist so angeordnet
wir schöne angenehme gefühl eine
bestimmung ist und ich höre natürlich
ist es in vielen fällen ist es einfacher
und wir haben das bei hotels bei
fluglinien bei der bahn bei vielen
bestimmungen sozusagen sehen wir es auch
da ist es nicht so schlimm das ist dann
mehr ärgerlich und unbequem hier ist es
existenziell zum teil und ich wir
brauchen das zeigt auch wieder wir sind
als gesellschaft noch nicht durch mit
dem thema kokona wir müssen noch mal
drüber reden was war vernünftig was war
überzogen was war unvernünftig und auch
ein bisschen wer hat sozusagen
unverhältnismäßig viel angst gemacht und
uns sozusagen eingeschüchtert das ist
nicht aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir
noch machen besteht die chance dass
aufgearbeitet wird also ich es muss also
ich setze sei immer auf das politische
instrument tatsächlich der
enquete-kommission weil ich finde das
gehört auf die bundestags eben auch weil
der bundestag sich selber als parlament
am anfang so fürchterlich rausgenommen
hat also so fürchterlich alles an die
exekutive an die regierung delegiert hat
und im grunde nicht anständig darüber
diskutiert darüber mit scheindebatten
die gar nicht ernst gemeint war das muss
eigentlich da auf großer bühne noch
einmal verhandelt werden es gibt ja auch
viele auch in den medien viele akteure
die sagen das sollte so sein das ist
notwendig aber wir müssen jetzt
dranbleiben wir sind natürlich jetzt
durch ein nächstes großes
mitreißendes und schlimmes geschehen
nämlich die den ukraine krieg natürlich
auch wieder gefangen genommen und
gefesselt und wir dürfen glaube ich
dieses große thema und was ist mit
unserer gesellschaft das tor nicht
vergessen also ich glaube sie wesentlich
ist zu sagen dass man das panikmache
kein guter ist also panik hilft nicht
das haben wir jetzt in den zwei jahren
auch erlebt panik schüren hilft nicht
sondern wie sie richtig sagen mit
augenmaß und die medien haben auch panik
gefährten ja wir haben alle fehler
gemacht also wir sind ja alle von dieser
welle wir waren unvorbereitet wir
wussten nicht was auf uns zukommt und
ich denke wir sind alle ein bisschen
klüger geworden und ich habe auch die
hoffnung dass das jetzt noch mehr mit
augenmaß wissen